[Music]
foreign
friends I am down at the Title Basin
here in southwest DC and the cherry
blossoms are blooming and I'm trying my
best not to be in anybody's way
um this is definitely my favorite time
of year here in the districts uh not
just because it means that spring is
here but also because I feel like
there's just a feeling of peace that I
get walking underneath these trees as
they're blooming that
it's really hard to replicate but it did
seem like a great opportunity to come on
down and teach you all just a little bit
about dancing Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of boys
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to teach
you a little bit about dancing with your
POI flowers but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinsky and Becca
becklenen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so like real talk it is gorgeous down
here but it also becomes that thing
where it's really really hard to stay
out of everybody's way especially during
Peak Bloom it is a Wednesday afternoon
and it's packed down here I cannot
imagine how busy it's going to be here
during the weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
flowers in some ways I kind of feel like
it's cheating to talk about dancing with
boy flowers because at least the way
that I learned the concept from Nick
Woolsey it seemed like dancing was the
entire point of learning them so I think
what I'm going to do here is I'm
actually going to take the tact of
saying that I'm going to teach you at
least one dance move for every timing in
Direction mode most of this is stuff
that I've picked up from other people
some of it is stuff that I've found
myself but I think all of it works
pretty well so let's start off by taking
a look at together same so straight up I
tend to find that together same as one
of the most difficult modes to dance
with it just feels the least like
natural human motion to me and so what I
tend to find works really well is
movements that involve hurling my body
through space and specifically torchites
there's also some points here for doing
some tuck turns going across the stage
but really for me it's these jumps that
make it
[Music]
when it comes to together opposite I
actually find that this is a great
timing in Direction mode for changing
levels but the thing I more commonly use
it for is just Chennai turns going back
and forth pivoting on just one foot as I
turn around in a circle
foreign
so what about split Time same direction
somewhat legendarily I am fond of using
split Time same direction anti-spin
flowers to do shunners across the stage
I've actually done a tutorial for this
move that I'll go ahead and link to down
in the description but it's still a
favorite I also have to say split Time
same direction makes for a great primer
for doing pirouettes as well
[Music]
wow
and finally that just leaves split time
opposites for which my favorite move is
literally just to take it back and forth
across the stage because the movement
already feels kind of lateral to me I
just use that to carry myself back and
forth and it works great
[Applause]
[Music]
so with all of that in mind here's a
demonstration of a bunch of these
different ideas in action so you can see
how you can use all these different
flowers to dance with
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
cool so what'd you think of these are
there dance moves that you do with your
flowers that I missed here that you
think I should have included on the list
go ahead and let me know down in the
comments please make sure to like share
comment and subscribe to help keep the
conversation going and of course to help
my channel grow
thank you
foreign
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous support and
if you out there watching are not
currently supporters but you'd like to
become supporters the way you can do
that is by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out more of my videos teaching you how
to dance with different POI tricks I
will go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow and I'll
see you with a new video real soon peace